[Musique]
et même si les vacances de la toussaint
sont quasiment terminées il reste encore
un week-end prolongé bonsoir mélanie
poker pour ça vous venez en plateau pour
vos idées de sorties loisirs du week-end
et et vous nous proposer cette semaine
un rendez-vous royal et oui grégory ses
week-ends c'est le retour de la course
royal la course pédestre organisée par
la commune de fontenay le fleury avec
versailles grand parc cette année plus
de 500 participants sont attendus à 10
heures sur la ligne de départ qui se
trouait la pièce d'eau des suisses à
versailles alors pourquoi ne pas vous
glisser parmi les 600 spectateurs le
long du parcours
quelques précisions avec l'adjoint au
maire qui était l'invité de michael
numéro lundi 28 octobre et on traverse
la plaine de versailles le parc du
château de versailles pour arriver dans
la commune de fontaines fleuries ya de
petites complications mais c'est
beaucoup plus de plat et avec ce qu on
dit dans le jargon découvrir un petit
casse pattes comment à la fin de course
pour leur faire voir que voilà c'est
donné c'est pas non plus une partie de
plaisir
alors deux épreuves au programme un 10
km une course nature de 20 km il ya
aussi une randonnée de marche nordique
est une course pour enfants à sur une
distance de deux kilomètres alors parmi
les participants vous pourrez voir
passer des équipes un peu particulière
puisque grâce à des joëlettes et des
bénévoles de plusieurs associations des
personnes à mobilité réduite vont
pouvoir concourir
c'est une course qui comprend les qui
comprend l'esprit des joëlettes c'est à
dire que souvent quand on s'inscrit
les organisateurs ne dise ok mais vous
vous mettez à l'arrière là les
organisateurs nous disent non devant on
a compris l'esprit c'est un partage les
personnes en situation de handicap sont
devant peuvent faire profiter à tout le
monde du fait de participer à cette
course donc c'est extraordinaire pour
nous alors il y aura plusieurs départs
qui seront donnés dans la matinée du
côté de versailles pour supporter les
marcheurs c'est à 9h45 les 10 et 20 km
s'élanceront à 10 heures et du côté de
fontenay le fleury les plus jeunes
participants seront à supporter dès 9h30
merci mélanie d'autres idées de sorties
dans votre émission c dans un instant le
7-8 loisirs sur tv 78